hers was a long Reign and many marking
her death say Queen Elizabeth II was a
constant in their lives in the Church of
England prayers are said every day for
the Monarch O Lord show thy mercy upon
us
and grant us thy salvation
O Lord Save the King
and mercifully hear us when we call upon
thee and while the sentiment Remains the
words have changed
it is a seamless change the
prayers are for the sovereign
for the queen and now for the King King
Charles
because we remember that The Sovereign
is the Supreme governor of the Church of
England Church of England has a
particular role in due time God willing
the church WIll crown and anoint the new
king
[Music]
the past week has seen rituals
stretching back centuries being played
out
[Music]
but in many ways the British queen
silently permeated areas of everyday
life here and in countries where she was
head of a state money bearing Her Image
will be phased out over a number of
years and replaced by that of a son King
Charles III
anyone under the age of 70 in the UK has
only known postage stamps with the
Queen's picture on them for seven
decades they chronicled her life it's
not going to be an immediate change
it'll be a gradual change
her late Majesty the queen approved the
stamps for the next two or three issues
and later this month we have an issue
for the Royal Marines then we've got uh
another issue coming up for the
treasures of Tutankhamun I think we'll
just have to wait and see what the new
king decides and that will be exciting
for us all
there will be other changes too one
theater in London is expected to alter
its name from her to his Majesty's
theater The Royal Cipher on uniforms
worn by officials and on Royal documents
will be replaced even at court the
highest lawyers in the land have changed
their name from Queens to King's Council
and the other day I think I signed the
first letter a formal letter about
something and I thought oh I better use
Casey
other than that there is no formal
difference
many of these changes are symbolic but
they do very much represent a Changing
of the Guard Emma Haywood Al Jazeera in
London